hello and welcome to the Yale 2020
website i'm kimberly gulf cruz secretary
and vice president for university life
although traditional commencement
ceremonies will have to wait until we
can meet in person we couldn't let this
time pass without celebrating all
members of the Yale University class of
2020 as you explore this site you'll
find content from the University and
from your schools we hope it will help
you reflect on your experience at Yale
and all you have accomplished will
continue to add content throughout the
week and after May 18th and will keep
the site live for several months we'd
really love to add your photos and your
videos you can contribute by using the
links on the website or hashtag Yale
2020 on social media on Monday May 18th
beginning at 11 a.m. Eastern Standard
Time President salivates addressed to
the students and the official conferral
of student and honorary degrees will be
live chaplain Kugler will also share a
blessing and many schools will follow
with their own programming we hope you
enjoy the site and on behalf of all of
us at Yale warm congratulations to our
graduates and their proud families and
friends